y seguir negociando hasta que se pueda
alcanzar ese gran acuerdo de glasgow que
permita cumplir ese objetivo que se
trazó incluso desde antes que se llegará
a esta cumbre y es mantener viva y
controlada la temperatura del planeta en
1.5 grados pero lo cierto es que a estas
alturas no hay certeza incluso de que se
vaya a ser el resultado las
negociaciones han durado y prácticamente
llevan dos semanas ininterrumpidas están
en este momento en su punto más álgido
negociadores representantes de 197
países se mantienen a puerta cerrada a
muy pocos metros de donde origina mos
esta transmisión de france 24 tratando
de llegar a un consenso un solo texto
con varias visiones recordemos 197
países participan en esta copa 26 están
tratando de llegar a un consenso después
de que se conociera este borrador que
reveló las dificultades que aún
persisten especialmente como ya tú
mencionabas algunas financiación para
los países en desarrollo que son los que
sufren y sufrirán más con los efectos
del cambio climático
el carbón como fuente de energía la
financiación de combustibles fósiles y
las pérdidas y los daños a los armas que
es el presidente de la 26 considera que
probablemente esta noche del viernes se
conocerá otro texto y que espera que sea
acogido por todos los miembros pero no
hay certeza de cuál sea la hora ni cuál
vaya a ser el contenido de este texto